So this is manganese metal. You know, very
often in chemistry we use manganese in the
form of permanganate as an oxidizing agent
but this is manganese metal.
Manganese is right in the middle of the row
of transition metals and it has 5 electrons,
which can give it a really very rich chemistry.
So here you can see it is a brand new sample
although the bottle looks very, very old,
it is 100grams. So I am going to pour a small
amount of manganese out, so that we can have
a closer look.
One of the main uses of manganese at the moment
is as a catalyst for making the plastic which
you find in plastic water bottles. You can
see my big display of water bottles up there.
And manganese is a key catalyst in the reaction
between xylene, which is the raw material
which you get from crude oil to make terephthalic
acid which is one of the components in this
plastic. And the reason it is important is
that manganese can add and lose electrons
which help in the reaction between xylene
and oxygen.
There is some paper on the top.
Manganese is also important in old batteries,
the older batteries that you used in torches,
the sort that leaked, contained manganese
dioxide.
So here we have the manganese and we are going
to pour a small amount out so that we can
have a look at this element. And you can see
how the colour refracts off the top, really
a quite lovely sample of the manganese metal
itself. So we are looking at manganese crystals
growing from the surface because this material
would have been made from a high temperature,
crystal growing-type process. So you can see
the manganese is growing and seeding new crystallites
of the surface - seeding off in every direction.
It’s cool.